una multitud de manifestantes irrumpió
en el palacio gubernamental de irak
chocando contra las fuerzas de seguridad
disparando al aire y bañándose en la
piscina de palacio
después de que el clérigo chiíta moqtada
al sádr anunciara su retirada final de
la política en twitter centenares de
seguidores interrumpieron una sesión del
gobierno con su furia
a esto se retiró de la política del todo
ahora la gente dirigirá la revolución
romana
hoy estamos frente a la gente no frente
al gobierno el pueblo está en la calle
aquí nos quedaremos no daremos marcha
atrás moriremos aquí estamos listos para
morir porque no tenemos nada que perder
la violencia escaló con rapidez los
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes algunos de ellos armados
han dejado varios muertos y decenas de
heridos
los disparos llegaron hasta la zona
verde de bagdad
el corazón de la presencia internacional
en la capital iraquí normalmente aislada
del tumulto
el propio al sádr un religioso que logró
su influencia oponiéndose a las
injerencias externas tanto de eeuu como
de iran se ha declarado en huelga de
hambre hasta que la violencia pare el
ejército impuso un toque de queda en
todo el país para que los seguidores del
clérigo dejen de ocupar las
instituciones sin éxito
de hecho los manifestantes llevan
sentados frente al parlamento desde
julio cuando entraron en el legislativo
para desalentar a los rivales políticos
de al sádr
el gobierno iraquí está bloqueado desde
que su partido ganó sin mayoría absoluta
a las elecciones parlamentarias en
octubre del año pasado y al sádr rechazó
negociar con los grupos chiítas
proiraníes
así irak lleva más de 10 meses sin
gabinete el período más largo de su
historia